In this part of our level editing,
I want to talk about landscape patches.
Now, landscape patches are a really great way
to define how the landscape will
be affected when a certain actor or group of actors
is placed in the level.
In the scene in front of us, we have an example of the two
types of patches that we have available.
We have a texture patch and a circle patch.
And the difference between them is this.
The texture patch allows us a much finer control
over how the surface is going to be affected.
In fact, in this example, what we're actually
using here is the crater texture
that was utilized in the landscape sculpting example.
And over on the right, you can see the circle height patch.
And this is just using a procedural circle
with a procedural falloff.
And you can see what it's having
an effect on the landscape.
Now, to work with this, it's very, very simple.
All we need to do is simply select the static mesh
or group of static mesh or actor
that's placed in the world.
And we can then click on Add.
And from the Add menu, we can add the landscape circle height
patch component or the landscape texture patch
component.
Once we've done that, the first time we're
going to be asked where we want
to insert this new edit layer.
And we do need a landscape patches edit layer.
And once we've done that, we will then
be able to adjust the settings.
And first things first, we do need to select the landscape.
So inside of either the circle height patch or the texture
patch, we do need to make sure
that landscape is selected.
And the best way to do this is
to simply click on the menu showing the landscape
and then selecting it.
Let's go ahead and pop over to the editor
and see how this works.
So first off, what we're going to do is right here,
I have just a very simple this floor right here,
which is right at the bottom of this.
I'm going to come here and add.
And we're just going to look for our L-A-N-D.
And there is our landscape circle height.
So notice again, nothing happened.
So I'm just going to come here and click
on my landscape.
And let's go ahead and kind of move this out a little bit.
There we go.
Whoops, made it a little bit too wide.
And maybe make this fall off a little bit more.
There we go.
The other thing we can do is with this selected,
we can actually move it up and down.
So that we can have something like that.
There we go.
Now, if we were to take all of these things together
and then put them into a level, create packed level
actor with all of this, when we bring that out,
it'll be able to do this really interesting offset
to the landscape.
So let's go ahead and we're going to come here.
And it's this brick right around here somewhere.
I believe it's this one.
So there we go.
So let's just delete this for the time being.
So we're going to delete that.
And let's come here to our land.
And we're going to add the texture patch.
So there we go.
So there's our texture patch.
And again, texture patch is going to look quite different.
So first off, let's make sure we get our landscape going
on in there.
And we can come here to our source mode.
And we can change this to, say, a texture asset.
And then I'm going to hit Control Space here.
We're going to look for our brushes.
We're going to take this impact graders.
And we can use that as our texture asset.
So there we go.
We are actually going to be offsetting by that.
We can then also reinitialize the height
to make sure that it's actually sitting on the right location.
And let's just set this to maybe like 3 by 3.
There we go.
And we might want to just bring it this way a little bit more.
And we're not getting a really good result here.
So let's go ahead and we can try adjusting the blend mode.
Let's see if Min will give us one.
Oops, and I didn't mean to do that.
So I'm going to hit Control Z. Let's just try Max.
And this is just affecting the way
that the texture here is going to be placed over the top.
And I'm just trying to find one that is going
to give me a little bit better.
Let's try our 0 to 1.
There we go.
That's what it was.
It was our 0 to 1.
A little bit better encoding so I can actually
see what's going on inside of the landscape.
And it was setting our 0 to 1 right there.
So we can also, I believe, change
this to give us a little bit more depth
inside of our landscape.
Oh, just there we go.
So you can see here that's actually affecting it
and adding those craters in there.
Remember, the landscape doesn't have too crazy amount
of tessellation.
We do have displacement available.
The actual individual landscape quads
are not super, super, super big.
So that's why sometimes this, whoops, and I set that up.
I want to keep that at 0.5.
So that's why sometimes we'll get these errors like this
is that if we just come here and we go to our wireframe,
remember, we don't have a crazy amount of detail
right here.
So just keep that in mind as you
are building this that oftentimes these foundations
are really going to work best when you have something that
is maybe more similar to, let's come back over here
to this twin mountain, to the mountain, I should say,
example.
And we're probably going to have to make this thing
really, really, really huge.
Yeah, there we go.
We got a little bit of fall off.
And then we probably need to like,
we could multiply this by 4 and multiply this one by 4.
There we go.
Something like that.
And then we would need to adjust the height of it
accordingly.
So just keep that in mind as you're utilizing this,
that the best results are going to come from something that
gives a subtle fall off.
And in many instances, I find that working
with the landscape patch that utilizes
just the rectangular fall off works really, really well.
So here, again, we can see this working in action here
for us.
We're getting some nice fall off.
And then, again, I can adjust this
to meet the needs of my building.
Or maybe I just come over here and move this down
and maybe scale it up a little bit to, oops, undo that.
And we'll just scale this back down.
There we go.
That works even better.
All right.
So that's how we would go about using those landscape
patches and the landscape circle height
patches to give us a really great foundation
underneath a building that we are creating.